[Music]
this guy is
did you guys enjoy this and learn
something
and it sounds like me versus false has a
verse that he would like to share to
prove
that mock that Moses was a Muslim and
win this for a hundred dollars let's go
all right so this is um Surah 20 verse
number 13 when Moses met Allah Allah
told them I am Allah and there is nobody
worship other than me so he worshiped
Allah now
if you look at the Paleo Hebrew
if you again go to paleo Hebrew
dictionary the god
his name is Allah Allah means the light
is light Allah okay and Yahweh is bad is
a devil so this is
Elijah when he came to Israelites he
told them why you worship God
and do not worship the Creator God so
these people were worshiping what did
you say his name was
whose name was you said a light you said
a lie what Elijah Elijah Elijah what
does Elijah mean
Eliza Elias what is it what does that
mean what does Elijah mean
I don't know that's your name we call
him Elias but you stole that you said no
I said we haven't in Hebrew it's Elijah
right yeah I I gave you easy I gave you
Arabic name which is Elias that's what
we call it in the in the heat in the in
the Hebrew what is his name
people don't know his name his name is
his name is Elijah right here I think
right I think a simple Wikipedia search
will give you his real name
oh yeah yeah so let's do this real quick
let's do a simple Wikipedia shirts I
like that
I like that a simple Wikipedia search
let's see
meaning
of the name
go to the Wikipedia you said you said do
a quick Wikipedia shirt that says uh
Yahweh is my God that's what that name
means no so I'll tell you what Elijah
means if you go to just I just I just
looked it up as you told me to and it
says Yahweh is my God so why is a
prophet named after the devil according
to you so his name if you go to the
Elijah Wikipedia page for Elijah his
name is Wikipedia for a page for Elijah
yes I just put up the meaning of Elijah
no no I don't want you it's Eli yeah
which means Yahweh is my God
no I want you to go to Wikipedia page
for Eliza which is awesome is that is
that not what it means no his Greek name
is Elias okay his Greek name is yes wait
was he Greek or was he Hebrew
no Greek took the name from Egypt Egypt
was was the Prophet Elijah Greek or
Hebrew he was from bani Israel children
of Israel so was he Greek or Hebrew he
was from Children of Israel so I'm gonna
ask you one last time was he Greek or
was he Hebrew Hebrew thank you and so
what does his name mean in the Hebrew
his name in the Hebrew is Elias
I didn't ask you what it no that's not
the name in the Hebrew the name in the
Hebrew is Elijah what does his name mean
in the Hebrew
my God is no it doesn't yeah my God is
who yeah yeah
no it's not yakia it's Yahweh no it's
not yeah
why are you saying that's your Prophet
because you're this is your profit yeah
the devil Prophet is named after the
devil my prophet name is Elias not is
your is your Prophet named after the
devil is my prophet name is Elias is
your Prophet named after the devil no
your Prophet is named after a devil so
then why does so then according to you
and because he I pray that I pray that
God has mercy on your soul for for
blaspheming his name in such a way but
you you according to you your Prophet is
named after the devil
this is what you want to argue according
to you your Prophet is you named him
devil and your God is also Yahweh is a
devil his wife is Ashira Yahweh is a
bald devil don't look at everything I
remember you I remember you all right so
um let's let's get back to this now so
Moses you said worshiped uh believed in
Allah
where do you get this from
2014 in Quran that's just a claim where
did we find that lot that Moses actually
believed in Allah because in the Paleo
Hebrew dictionary Allah
it looks like jabriel caught your
connection sorry paleo Hebrew dictionary
paleo Hebrew dictionary Allah is the
name of God where do you find the story
of Moses
in Quran it's really in the Quran so
it's in the yep okay it's in the Quran
it's in the Quran
um was Moses an Israelite
Moses was
from Egypt I didn't ask that
no he wasn't he wasn't in
here you guys go this is this is clip so
Moses was not an Israelite ladies and
gentlemen he was bunny Israel what is
that
children of Israel who's Israel
all sorts of people
who is when you say the children of
Israel who is Israel mostly mostly uh
dark colored Africans
I didn't ask for skin tone who is Israel
when you say the children of Israel
characters jacob jacob Jacob and he's
like wait wait wait wait wait wait where
do you find that Jacob is Israel
it says in Quran show me
what do you mean
show me the verse how it says that
Israel is Jacob
Israel because his name is Bernice his
name is show me show me that Jacob is
called Israel show me the Quran we have
an entire world show me the whole verse
Jacob is Israel
Lucas Surat 17 is called bani Israel
okay can you show me the verse that says
that Jacob is Israel in that in that
chapter
it's the entire verse Surah is called
ban Israel I don't care what the I don't
care what the chapter is called show me
in the chapter that Jacob is called
Israel
uh show me that
um
Moses
[Music]
is this
simple no
go get the syrup go get the syrup Stacy
listen it's either you do this bro
because I don't like my time wasted
because you came up here you came up
here talking mess and stuff like that so
this is why I gotta treat you like the
Demi that you are it's either you show
me the verse where Jacob is called
Israel or you can just be honest for
once in your life for once in your life
as a disbelieving pagan and say you know
what I lied the Quran doesn't say that
and I don't know what who Israel is I
have to use other things other than the
Quran just admit that and I will have
respect for you brother can I correct
something about this uh Hebrew okay so
first off God's name in Hebrew is not
Allah it is no it's
we don't know the actual pronunciation
you don't know that I prefer actually I
know the name of God we know the name of
God you don't know it's literally you
don't know how to pronounce
it your sentence is interrupting mine
apparently so apparently
um so we don't know how to pronounce it
so some people say adenine or Hashem in
in reference to the name instead of
saying
and in terms of the Torah we can prove
that Moishe Moses was a Hebrew because
throughout the story of the five books
of the pentateuch we can see remarkable
similarity in Moses in that Yahweh
chooses Moses and gives him not just uh
you know a a responsibility to fulfill
the promises that he had given to you
know Jacob and Isaac and all the people
in Genesis in Genesis like 22-25
um we can literally see the same God
gives him the promise it says hey you
are now in charge of X of of executing
the uh the Covenant that I have given
him which results in the law at side
resulting in the in the streaming of not
just the Jews but all people to worship
God
and Mount Sinai
says like Yahweh yeah so can you go can
you go to the Quran verse and show me
where Jacob is called Israel can I
answer him first no you're supposed to
answer me first I gave you the entire
verse no show me the verse go into your
Quran go into your corrupted book and
show me where Jacob is called Israel we
have a entire chapter show me it
show me that Jacob is called Israel what
are you deaf you know how many times we
have bunnies I don't care about children
what Benny is what does Benny mean bunny
means Son thank you son of
who Israel who is that his if his name
is Yahoo where do you find that Israel
is Yahoo show me that
because Allah Prophet said that
show me what do you show you show me
where your Prophet said that
I have to search but we know this okay
[Laughter]
listen listen me versus false and
literally it is me versus false listen
you have time I'm giving you time you
got about five minutes to go off the app
and go search and look where in your
Quran look where in your Quran Israel
show me it you got five minutes
you got five minutes bro
Yahweh as a devil you got five minutes
devil y'all got five minutes
you got five minutes come back when you
find the verse
freaking jokes also
um he got the names wrong where he said
yeah yeah I think he was saying
something about that was John
um yeah yeah even has ironically enough
it even has the name of our God in it
yeah yeah it means Yahweh is uh merciful
so I don't know why he was coming up
with all this weird stuff he was logic
[Music]
thank you